former FBI director james comey slams
President Trump in his first major
interview since the president fired him
11 months ago commis new memoir details
his brief working relationship with the
president who suggested yesterday that
Comey should be in jail in the interview
that aired last night Comey claimed mr.
Trump does not have the moral fitness to
be President and said he might be
susceptible to Russian blackmail Paula
Reid is at the White House Paula good
morning a good morning in this interview
the former FBI chief described the first
time that he met the president and his
staff saying that they reminded him of
mobsters that he used to track as a
young prosecutor and while he says that
he does believe mr. Trump is intelligent
enough to be President he does not
believe that that is enough to make you
fit to lead I think he's morally unfit
to be President
former FBI director James Comey took aim
at President Trump who fired him last
May unleashing a stream of attacks on
the president's character a person who
sees moral equivalence in
Charlottesville who talks about and
treats women like their pieces of meat
who lies constantly about matters big
and small and insists the American
people believe it that person is not fit
to be President of the United States on
moral grounds are you thinking president
Trump's a liar yes the president tried
to get ahead of the interview tweeting
Sunday morning that Comey was slippery
and a slimeball that he hardly even knew
in his most explosive charge Comey said
the president could have obstructed
justice when he asked him to let go of
the investigation and a former National
Security Advisor Mike Flynn he's asking
me to drop a criminal investigation of
his now former national security adviser
president says he didn't say that yeah
what am I gonna do he did it was
president Trump obstructing justice
possibly I mean it's certainly some
evidence of destruction of justice
Comey said that his belief that Hillary
Clinton would win the election played a
role in how he handled the FBI
investigation into her personal email
servers as Hillary Clinton wrote in her
book I shift her I mean that sounds like
I was trying to knife somebody I was out
to get her and it's an illustration of
our polarization here that you've got
the Trump camp which I guess thinks
I was trying to save Hillary Clinton if
you knew that letter would elect Donald
Trump you'd still send it I would in
their first meeting Comey briefed the
president-elect on evidence showing
Russian interference in the 2016
election present electrons first
question was to confirm that it had no
impact on the election no one to my
recollection asked so what's coming next
from the Russians how might we stop it
what's the future look like there was
none of that
the former FBI director said he could
not rule out the possibility that mr.
Trump has been compromised by the
Russians yeah it is stunning and I wish
I wasn't saying it but it's just it's
the truth and Comey didn't just attack
the president's leadership he also
attacked him personally his appearance
his marriage even his ties and it's
those kinds of very personal attacks
that bolster the president's claim there
are many people in federal law
enforcement who were out to get him John
well I director Comey is sounding the
alarm bell now about president Trump but
during the campaign there is an argument
that he had a different standard for the
two different candidates how is he
responding to that certainly well he's
trying to argue that he believed that
the Secretary Clinton was the inevitable
candidate that she would be elected and
he wanted to protect the integrity of
her presidency and that's why he felt
that he had to have that press
conference and explain why no charges
were being brought something that's
really unprecedented and also why he
said that letter to Congress just days
before the election saying there were
new emails that have been discovered
even if you didn't know if they were
significant but at the time having
covered this so closely I'd never
remember him actually raising any red
flags about now President Trump and it
did appear that he was very concerned
about protecting the reputation and the
integrity and appearance of the FBI in
the context of the Clinton investigation
and not so much Clinton herself speaking
of the integrity of investigations does
this book get in the way of what special
counsel Muller is trying to do I don't
think it has much impact on that
investigation because most of the claims
that have come out there are things that
Muller already knew or things that Comey
foreshadowed in his congressional
testimony all right Paula Thanks any
bets on whether the president watched
last night I don't think no I don't
think so I think his reaction is baked
in you know it's one thing that's
at the investigation there's a huge
moral claim that James Comey is making
here and anybody who wants to defend the
president it seems to me is able to say
he is morally and ethically fit to serve
and he serves by the same standards I
use that's the separate question of
whether he tried to obstruct her didn't
try to obstruct there's this question of
whether he meets the test for the moral
leadership yeah she said he had higher
than average IQ in his opinion yeah
right that's interesting